a voice so hilarious it cost this actor
a role in the Star Wars Universe turning
down a sought after superhero role
because of a potential nickname those in
Hollywood can be cold cruel unforgiving
and sometimes tardy
Olivia Wilde has enjoyed a rocket ride
to the A-list in the last few years with
roles in critically acclaimed features
like a vigilante and Richard Jewell and
praise for her directorial debut book
smart however she's also put in the
hours auditioning for and sometimes
failing to land roles one notable loss
for wild was the part that eventually
made Margot Robbie a star in Martin
scorsese's Wolf of Wall Street Howard
Stern asked Wilde in a 2016 interview if
she had ever lost a part because the
producers considered her too attractive
Wilde replied that she recalled being
turned down for a movie because she was
too sophisticated she recalled I was
like oh that sounds nice and then I
found out later that they actually said
old I want to make a translation sheet
for Hollywood that's all the feedback
your agents give you and what it really
means
oh
now I feel foolish Wilde later revealed
that the film in question was The Wolf
of Wall Street and she was 29 at the
time of the audition she went on to note
that the experience ultimately proved
beneficial as it forged a connection
with Scorsese that led her to joining
the cast of The short-lived HBO series
vinyl she added it shows that if you
don't get something job interview
whatever you do for a living it might
lead to something else
I have the tingle thing just not for
bread the triumphant return of Andrew
Garfield as Spider-Man in Spider-Man no
way home had many fans wondering why he
had left the Marvel film series in the
first place it was likely a combination
of reasons from the box office stumble
between his two Spidey films to a
growing disenchantment with the
portrayal of the character however the
most Petty reason playing a part in his
dismissal was revealed as part of the
infamous 2014 hack of internal emails at
Sony Garfield was slated to appear at a
Sony event in Rio de Janeiro in 2014
then Studio chairman kazuo harai planned
to announce him as the star of The
Amazing Spider-Man 3 slated for 2016.
but while Garfield came to Rio he did
not show up to the event citing fatigue
from jet lag this forced harai to
scramble at the last minute scrapping
the announcement the Chairman's
displeasure was evident in his leaked
email here we are about one hour away
from our Gala event and Andrew decides
he doesn't want to attend he has a
rather scruffy beard and he just wants
to be left alone though never confirmed
as the specific reason for his dismissal
Garfield and Sony parted way soon after
the Rio event dust up
Witcher star Henry Cavill has made it no
secret that he'd like to drive the Aston
Martin as James Bond now that Daniel
Craig has retired as 007. in 2020 he
told GQ that if the James Bond producers
were interested in him joining the
Legacy he would happily jump at the
opportunity however Cavill already made
strides to play the iconic secret agent
back in 2006 and according to an
interview with Men's Health U.S in 2021
he received feedback that might leave
most actors feeling shaken not stirred
in the men's health article cavil said
he auditioned for Bond prior to Daniel
Craig's Assumption of the role in 2006's
Casino Royale cavil said he was one of
the finalists for the role that is until
the screen test required him to wear
only a bath towel he recalled I remember
the director Martin Campbell saying
looking a little chubby there Henry
though Cavill endured teasing for his
weight as a kid he took the comment
since stride he said I'm glad Martin
said something because I respond well to
truth it helps me get better the truth
about you
beautiful
as fans of the 2005 dystopian flick V
for Vendetta no British actor James
pierfoy was initially cast as the
titular anti-hero who terrorizes a
totalitarian future England government
he Departed the role after three weeks
of filming reportedly due to
difficulties in wearing the character's
signature guy Fox mask director James
mcteague alluded to this account in an
interview with cbr.com saying it's hard
putting anyone in a mask actor Hugo
weaving who replaced Purefoy as V also
hinted that the mask was the source of
the problem in an interview he said I
was very surprised to get the call
saying well look we've actually sort of
parted ways with James Purefoy it was to
do with animating the mask and they
didn't think it was working however
Purefoy appeared to counter that account
in an interview with total film saying
the only rumor I can Scotch is that if
anybody thinks I was too to wear a mask
they're completely wrong Purefoy also
laughed off rumors that producer Joel
Silver dismissed him because his voice
lacked Menace claiming that they really
just parted ways because of creative
differences whose version is correct it
remains a subject for debate
auditions can be a difficult process for
any performer if they fail to book the
part they or their representation are
sometimes told by the filmmakers why
they weren't right for the role for many
actors this can be a swift kick in the
ego and a real damper to the confidence
necessary to work in that field however
any actor should take comfort in the
fact that even some of the greatest in
their business were dismissed for petty
even downright rude reasons case in
point Oscar winner Meryl Streep arguably
one of the greatest actors in the
history of film and certainly the most
awarded in 1976 she was invited to
audition for producer Dino dilaurentis's
high profile remake of King Kong but as
she explained during a 2015 appearance
on The Graham Norton Show her audition
ended almost as quickly as it had begun
delaurentis's son asked her to try out
for the role of dwan eventually played
by Jessica Lang however upon arriving at
the production office Streep quickly
found out that she was not what the
veteran producer had in mind the father
said to his son in Italian because I
understand Italian
the you know why do you bring me this
ugly thing ultimately Streep had the
last laugh Kong was a box office flop
while she appeared in the deer hunter in
1978 netting her first of 21 Oscar
nominations I'm sorry I'm not beautiful
enough to be in King Kong
although Paul Bettany is best known for
films like The Da Vinci Code and solo a
Star Wars story and for playing the
mcu's vision he was primarily an English
stage and television actor until 2001.
during that period he came under
consideration to play Emmett Reese
Witherspoon's romantic interest in
Legally Blonde in a 2021 oral history of
Legally Blonde in the New York Times
casting director Joseph Middleton said
there was one fatal flaw in casting
betony as Emmett I loved Paul Bettany
for the Emmett role but he was British
and the producers felt like it needed to
be a real American
tell me a joke though Bettany didn't get
to be part of an enduring fan favorite
he did land the role of Jeffrey Chaucer
in A Knight's Tale that same year that
led to a successful career in Hollywood
via films like a beautiful mind and
Master and Commander The Far Side of the
World
back in 2000 Russell Crowe was one of
the biggest stars in Hollywood with an
Oscar for Gladiator and hit films like
LA Confidential and The Insider the
X-Men were also on their way to Grace
the Silver Screen for the first time and
fan favorite character Wolverine was
perhaps the most in-demand role in town
it seems only natural then that the
irritable rage-filled mutant and the
actor known for playing irascible
rage-filled characters would intersect
But ultimately the Australian turned it
down for very curious reasons while
appearing on the daytime television
program Fitzy and whippa in 2017 Crow
was asked why he turned down the role of
Wolverine and X-Men the actor was
director Brian singer's First Choice to
play the iconic Marvel mutant but as
Crow explained he'd already had his fill
of wolves while on Gladiator if you
remember Maximus has a wolf at the
center of his querass and he has a wolf
as His companion which I thought was
going to be a bigger deal at the time so
I said no because I didn't want to be
wolfy like Mr Wolf as Crow later found
out Gladiator director Ridley Scott
trimmed much of said wolf reference
referencing from the Final Cut but
something good did come out of Crow's
loss he suggested fellow Aussie actor
Hugh Jackman for the role of Wolverine
helping his countrymen create one of the
great iconic roles of the 21st Century
I am Spider-Man and I really messed up
wait
you're you're being serious right now
you're not joking with me like you're
100 serious because it's not funny actor
Tom Holland recalled an instance in
which laughter upended a very important
audition on a 2021 episode of the
YouTube series hot ones while doing his
best to endure a variety of scalding hot
sauces Holland recalled that his
audition to play Finn in Star Wars the
Force awakens was ruined by his scene
partner who was voicing a Droid Holland
explained I just remember thinking
there's no way this lady is going to
read the robot's lines opposite me
because that would be ridiculous but she
did read those lines and Holland
couldn't get over it he added this lady
bless her would sit there with full
commitment and was like beep beep as a
result Holland couldn't take the
audition seriously he got a case of the
giggles and just couldn't stop laughing
while he didn't end up joining the Star
Wars franchise Holland did land the
coveted role of Spider-Man which is
maybe the greatest consolation prize
ever
[Music]